huge new developments in the Mex its
Agha a source tells ET that Prince Harry
and Megan Markel will officially say
goodbye to their status as senior Royals
on March 31st their buckingham palace
offices will close the following day on
April 1st and well cue the start of
their new foundation office and their
new roles but Megan and Harry still have
a few royal duties on the books before
this transition happens according to our
source the couple will arrive back in
London on February 28th like last year
they'll attend the endeavor fund Awards
on March 5th the ripple effect will see
Harry at the Silverstone experience with
Lewis Hamilton on the 6th there's the
Mountbatten Music Festival on March 7th
and of course Megan will attend various
International Women's Day events on
March 8th I hope that men are part of
the conversation my husband certainly is
Megan and Harry are also scheduled to
appear at the Commonwealth Service on
March 9th and get this a royal source
confirms that going forward the Sussex
is will be in the UK more than we
initially thought
Harry's calendar includes the London
Marathon in April he'll attend as a
patron and he and Megan will of course
support the Invictus games in the
Netherlands this May the source as Harry
will continue his involvement with the
games as well as his dedication to the
military and mental health causes we're
never really satisfied I'm not proud
until in my mind that we've actually
really made a difference that for me is
the definition of success
what's more the Sussex is still have
time to change their minds about their
royal exit we've got a thrive if you've
got to feel happy for the palace Megan
Harry and the royal family have agreed
to a 12-month review to make sure
everyone's happy with the arrangements
during this 12-month period
Harry will keep his military ranks
though they won't be used and there
won't be any new appointments made
to completion of the revealed it's very
easy to to completely forget about who I
am when I'm in the army I am one of the
guys I don't get treated any differently
as for their titles
they'll keep them all the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex the Earl and Countess
of Dumbarton and the Baron and Baroness
of kill-kill I never thought my life
would be that awesome but there's one
catch they might have to drop the word
royal from their branding a source tells
ET that is Meghan and Harry are stepping
back the use of the word royal in this
context needed to be reviewed the source
adds that discussions are still ongoing
the news comes after ET learns that
Meghan and herring had brainstorming
meetings with professors at Stanford
University last week in connection with
their new charitable organization our
source says that details about the
foundation will be shared in due course
I hope that helps you understand what
did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
[Music]